okay lawyer so so tell me where you're
from
my name is Floyd I'm from Texas and came
to skid row with I can't ask it go back
in the back in the mid-80s with drugs we
use almost all I used to I used to sell
cocaine no I got turned on hard to cook
it know how to cut it in know how to
sell it
God I will I was from this country you
know I want to make some fast money and
that's what I did figure figure out you
all the peoples schooling me Timmy how
to do it you know how to sell it and
stuff like that
what sells what what sold more the
powder or the rock to see a but a lot of
people back then like the rock the
really like boom but when you are
selling boat he don't give much time for
the powder indeed do right do you feel
like the rock is the jerk of people of
color and the powder is for the mostly
rich people that's not power or any of
your customers with
from other parts of the city as well as
here in the city right
yeah these come from you know Hollywood
Santa Monica you know all over basically
all over yes you're the place together
mm-hm yes how much money would you make
typically tonight well I will but mostly
tonight the night time I will make about
maybe fifteen or sixteen hundred or more
and how I mean like how I mean we're
there like other dealers that were like
here infringing on their territory or
vice versa do you know everything is we
didn't already know bagged even know had
that problem because being downtown is
neutral we don't have that probably if I
go to someone else's hood or other side
of town you know I might have some
confliction but downtown of it in
neutral downtown where the cops ever get
jail for rent
yeah yeah I got I got thrown in jail my
first time going to jail out here was in
86 then I got out because it was a
simply protection but you know but
identity then chip on no cocaine like to
do now because everybody knows too much
about it you know another thing too you
won't know having a big effect on people
like it dude to this day because they
put a whole bunch of cut and a whole
bunch of different chemicals in there
then you have some cocaine now maybe
maybe I'm just maybe maybe fifteen to
thirty percent cocaine and the rest of
it some garbage because I don't take
just a little cocaine base now for you
to go to jail to prison for you know and
stuff like that how many years really
okay I went to prison I went to prison
I got out for doing a seven years and
eight months
I got a January 1st 2018 I went for
conspiracy cases because they said that
I sold to a undercover which they they
had no more money or no dope on me only
reason why they come victim of my past
it could make my my past at further to
say
I stink sold to under the fire blackmail
that would destroy it further than said
I sold to only colors didn't cover no
more money or no not college okay they
gave me they gave me 17 years okay we're
doing with good behavior and
rehabilitation myself in prison I got on
about 57 which I did seven years and
eight months my release day were
November the 23rd 2023 because I was 17
years of 80% you do 13 years and four
months yes and did you River drugs a
part of childhood you know you know
judge no does never was a part of my
childhood I really didn't know nothing
about joy to our came to a California I
was doing good in school I was good
actually you know in knowing school when
I came out here I was good at to me but
maybe for the country and making this
type of money was overwhelming and
didn't I like this I like that you know
and stuff like that did you ever use
yourself no I never use no I know who
you I never use no drugs anything I
don't the drug I try then we in last
my smoke some weed was in 94 I'm not
into it I'm not into it though and they
tell me about the lifestyle so what
hours would you keep what you were
selling well robberies in school are
charging I know I try the hell gonna
finish my no basketball practice stuff
so I can come out and sell it at least
about 10 o'clock because I gotta be in
the house and go to school and you're
next so the next month yeah yeah no no
10:00 at night I try to no I go to
school right then I got to school I got
practicing and - uh - about - about fold
between four and five maybe six then
when I get I'll be trying to hammer and
get to a practice I couldn't get out and
make some money before 10 o'clock at
night okay that's what my curfew tonight
yeah do your nights yes did you ever do
that own weekend is that dealing with
yeah weekend's just and
which
so your customers would just know what
would corner you stood out or yes you
know yeah you know they did you know
when you build your clientele of people
gonna look for you people ain't gonna go
to no way up because they know they're
gonna get beat no they don't get robbed
they don't get treated fairly well not
when I used to sail I used to cheat my
customer fairly I just treat him first
yeah yeah they always can count over yes
yeah you know and a lot of addicts down
here in Skid Row so you have these
people right here in the neighborhood or
via yeah do you know since I've been out
you know people still talk to me and ask
me do you got anything anything no I'm
working I got my life together
I'm not doing it
yes they are very lightweight yes
yeah so so your wife that way yeah so
she passed away in 2010 Oh while I was
in prison your wives and it
no I had no sooner Oh No yeah moaning
yes what was the craziest thing you
remember like when you were selling but
kind of I'm sure you had stories in your
you do this yes
claims it the crazy dank you see they
have no females know the greatest tip
for the Fat Duck you know and stuff you
know they do any time you know no for
that product you know when you don't
have no money
yeah you know he know I look back at it
now I really know
no feel bad that higher tip awareness of
vulnerable people in that situation when
you feeling and stuff like that you know
beyond a bit you know as a lawyer you
don't forgive me for all the people that
I've heard in that so that stuff too you
know it out my conscience is clear you
know and I'm I'm doing that lifestyle
you know and do it you know it took me a
while to wake up and learn that
and if you like that no donor this is
better ways in life know that hustle
show money so money is human you know
you don't gotta worry about they're
gonna be show them you got not five
don't you read it dumb but words I see
yourself five years well well I see
myself in five years I was gonna
continue to work and I like to be you
know a counselor you know I got I got a
certificate in that field via counselor
help people out you know and don't make
the same mistakes I made in my past
because selling drugs it's not no
there's not no future than that you know
it took me a later age to realize that
now I woke up forced to later
no I'm still blessed with my help you
know you know and stuff like that you
know
you know five year that's like help
people not that could be a castle you
are come sir alright thank you sir okay